This is the kitchen area of the
Edacity. The coffee machines and two refrigerators,
well let's go look at them. Look
inside the refrigerator compartment, two controls. One labeled
freezer, one labeled refrigerator with numbers four,
two, what does that mean? How do you
use it, how do you set it?
It's a bad conceptual model. Now interestingly enough,
Edacity has two refrigerators, and they have different models. The other
one has the correct conceptual model. Here, let me show you.
If a refrigerator. The control's on the outside. One marked freezer, the
temperature four degrees Fahrenheit. The other
marked refrigerator with a temperature 37 degrees
Fahrenheit. Makes it really easy to set. Really easy to understand exactly what
is happening. The good conceptual model which we also discussed in the lesson.